ist kanzler scholz ein ehrlicher mensch
diese frage um die geht es heute das ist
der schwierigste tag für ihn seitdem er
kanzler ist denn deutschland erwartet
die ganze wahrheit jetzt von olaf scholz
kein ich kann mich nicht erinnern
sondern klartext und ehrlichkeit der
kanzler heute im kreuzverhör im
sogenannten comex untersuchungsausschuss
diesen riesigen steuerskandal ja da soll
scholz also nachher alles was er weiß
auf den tisch legen endlich wirklich
alles und direkt vor beginn dieses
scholz fairhurst haben uns die
bild-reporter nochmal neue details
aufgedeckt neue details aus der
[Musik]
aktuellen woche für kanzler olaf scholz
der kanzler unter druck wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
da
heute stolz verhöre
untersuchungsausschuss zum sogenannten
comex kanal es geht um die wahrheit herr
bundeskanzler erinnern sie sich sagen
sie die ganze ware darum geht es der
hamburger warburg bank wurden steuer
nachzahlungen in höhe von 47 millionen
euro einfach erlassen
damals regierte in hamburg olaf scholz
war das wirklich nicht seine
entscheidung keine politische
einflussnahme bild hat nun exklusive
einblicke in die akte comex bekommen
beweislage ist ziemlich ziemlich dicht
es wird schwierig für den bundeskanzler
die vielen widersprüche und sein
unerklärliches schweigen und vergessen
zu erklären
erst vor einer woche hatte scholz alle
unangenehmen journalisten fragen zu
seiner rolle im comic skandal einfach
ablegen wird auch von den 200.000 euro
schließfach seines hamburger spd
kollegen cars weist der kanzler
angeblich nicht
ich habe keinen anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft
der kanzler unter massivem druck in
einer höllenwoche finger nach seinem
unwürdigen auftritt mit dem
palästinenserpräsident abbas nachdem er
die ganze schuld für sein schweigen auch
sein sprecher show und dann habe ich wie
ich schon gesagt habe den fehler gemacht
nicht darauf zu reagieren bzw
nicht selber eine lücke zu lassen so
dass der bundeskanzler reagieren kann
doch scholz steht weiter im sturm
ausgebuht und niedergebracht bei einer
bürgersprechstunde im brandenburgischen
neuruppin
[Musik]
und internationale
atomenergieorganisation zugang bekommen
haben wird zum gelände und das werte
schafft
eine höllenwoche für den kanzler mit dem
höhepunkt heute in verhör auftritt vom
untersuchungsausschuss comex herr
bundeskanzler oder scholz geht es um
alles geht für ihn um das kanzleramt es
geht für ihn um die macht und es gibt
mit möglicherweise sogar um die macht
für die sozialdemokratische partei nicht
nur in hamburg sondern in ganz
deutschland
der kanzler unter druck wie nie
[Musik]
um die fische und bild live jetzt
matthias hauer cdu finanzexperte im
bundestag
herr auer was ist die wichtigste frage
die olaf scholz heute
beantworten muss
olaf scholz muss die frage beantworten
was ist seine persönliche rolle in
diesem millionen steuert und wieso hat
er sich mit kriminellen getroffen hat
spenden von diesen kriminellen bankern
für die hamburger spd angenommen was ist
mit den unstimmigkeiten in seinem
persönlichen kalender und seinem e mail
postfach
er wird da reinen tisch machen müssen
und sollte aufhören völlig abwegige
erinnerungslücken vorzuschieben auf
fragen zu comics von journalisten von
politikern
antwortet der bundeskanzler bisher
auffällig einsilbig ausweichend und dass
wir die leute nicht gelingen vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss sind sie sich da
so sicher denn genau das gelingt dem
jahr seit so langer zeit also jetzt
mache ich mal den scholz und sagt den
ganzen tag hier keine ahnung ich kann
mich nicht erinnern wer weiß ich nicht
mehr da können sie doch gar nichts
machen
ein untersuchungsausschuss kann sehr gut
nachfragen hat auch
ermittlungsmöglichkeiten die auch einem
strafgericht nahe kommen und es geht bei
einem solchen vorgang einer solchen
dimension auch vertrauen und
glaubwürdigkeit in den bundeskanzler und
vertrauen und glaubwürdigkeit ist in der
politik das a und o und scholz ist
völlig unglaubwürdig er selbst hat comex
als riesen schweinerei bezeichnet der
doch hat er sich persönlich in seinem
hamburger amtszimmer mit diesen
kriminellen getroffen die genau diesen
steuer raubt zu lasten der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
betrieben haben er will sich jetzt immer
nur an das erinnern was ohnehin schon
öffentlich bekannt geworden ist und dass
sich scholz nicht mehr an einen vorgang
dieser dimension erinnern kann indem er
sich persönlich mehrfach mit diesen
kriminellen getroffen hat bei dem es um
die existenz einer wichtigen hamburger
bank ging und schließlich sogar das
bundesfinanzministerium die notbremse
ziehen musste dass er sich an das nicht
mehr erinnern kann das ist völlig
unglaublich und im übrigen hat er sich
auch schon mal an einem solcher treffen
vor dem deutschen bundestag erinnert in
einem ausschuss später sind dann ist
dann bekannt geworden durch
investigative journalisten dass es zwei
weitere treffen gegeben hat und seitdem
erinnert er sich an keines dieser
treffen mehr und ich glaube das wird
noch mal deutlich werden der
bundeskanzler ist unglaubwürdig und der
steuerskandal ist für scholz auch
politisch hoch explosiv
glaubwürdigkeit und vertrauen im
politischen geschäft so ganz besonders
wichtig aber natürlich in jedem umgang
mit menschen halten sie olaf scholz für
einen ehrlichen menschen
er hat zumindest dem deutschen bundestag
nicht die wahrheit gesagt er sagt auch
vor der öffentlichkeit nicht die
wahrheit also aller indizien also nach
nein alle richtig alle indizien deuten
darauf hin dass scholz viel stärker als
bisher vermutet im sumpf diese
steuerskandals drinsteckt und die
staatsanwaltschaft findet ja nahezu
täglich neues belastendes material viel
bargeld im bankschließfach von seinem
spd genossen cast belastende
chatprotokolle in dem es darum geht
einen teuflischen plan aufgehen zu
lassen unstimmigkeiten in den kalendern
und postfächern von scholz und deshalb
muss auch die kommunikation von scholz
komplett lückenlos unter die lupe
genommen werden die staatsanwaltschaft
ist ja auch dran und ich sage ihnen
scholz dann auch schon vor allem anderen
untersuchungsausschuss einmal eingeräumt
dass er auch zu dienstlichen fragen von
nicht dienstlichen adressen
kommunizieren damit nämlich dinge auch
nicht verachtet werden und so gelingt es
ihm sachen aus den akten rauszuhalten
und wieso soll er dabei comics anders
vorgegangen sein und das hat ist es
genau richtig ist dass die
staatsanwaltschaft auch die mails zum
beispiel von scholz einer vertrauten
seiner büroleiterin durchsucht hat und
die funde der staatsanwaltschaft sind
für scholz hochexplosiv in einer
immerhin geht es darum zum beispiel dass
in den mails darüber diskutiert wird ob
daten gelöscht werden sollen und
inwieweit die öffentlichkeit und politik
informiert bzw vor allem nicht
informiert werden soll also habe nach
ihren einschätzungen kann olaf scholz
heute eigentlich nur verlieren vielen
dank
sagt schon jetzt kein ehrlicher mensch
und das also heute das event am frühen
nachmittag tag alle schauen auf diesen
untersuchungsausschuss wir tun das für
sie bild live den ganzen tag über diese
entwicklung indem scholz fallhöhe heute
in hamburg ab 14 uhr da muss die ganze
wahrheit sagen endlich
[Musik]